not Canadian I molded in Canada
long before my grandfather's were born
the death
we will here we speak stuff about the
land you know if you hear many people
rapping stuff about the land and the
water you'll hear that in the native
hip-hop community we're really more
genuine to the real point of what
hip-hop was supposed to be and that's a
way for the impoverished oppressed
people to finally get their voice back I
don't like it to be over romanticized I
don't like there to be false
expectations I see some people they
approach us and like maybe in the
activist community some of the
non-native activists they'll look
they'll come up to us like as if we have
some special power it's not true it's
not real and when I say hot I mean go
and fly your is gonna tell you what
building inside this land belong to us
not you history you teach in school the
stereotypes are definitely out there
people are expecting us to be drunk
violent incompetent human beings and
we're definitely proving the wrong every
one of these people are breaking those
stereotypes and I support them one more
download the aj+ mobile app and join the
conversation available in your app store
now